the 60 40 strategy the problem with that
strategy according to Mark is that
you're giving up a lot of upside in the
market and that's really where your
Returns come from and the market has
historically done pretty well the
problem is that the market can be really
volatile sometimes and go down a lot if
you protect yourself during those
volatile times and you have a trade that
will give you this big infusion of cash
when everything is down and are more
attractive you're going to do pretty
well
all right guys bang bang I've got Scott
Patterson here Scott is the author of
chaos Kings how Wall Street Traders make
billions in the new age of Crisis it's a
fantastic book uh specifically covering
Nasim taleb and Mark spitznagel Scott I
thought a great place for us to start
our conversation would be around this
idea of a crisis hunter that is a phrase
that is used a couple of times in the
book and seems to be a great way to
label what these guys are doing is that
a new concept or have people always been
kind of hunting crisis it's just now
with the way that the finance industry
is set up you can actually make money
off of it
yeah it's interesting crisis Hunter was
what they uh the same and Mark call
themselves when they launched their
first hedge fund empirica
and uh it was also one of the original
titles of the book
uh crisis Hunters
um talking with the publisher we changed
it to chaos Kings it's a little catchier
but they so they invented this concept
back in the late 90s uh it evolved in
their first hedge fund empirica and as
far as I know no one had ever created a
strategy like this that delivers these
explosive returns when the market
crashes and it was pretty successful
back then they shut it down mainly
because Nasim uh couldn't handle the
stress of the trading because it's it's
a very stressful strategy because you
actually lose a lot you're uh
consistently you don't you don't lose a
lot of money but you're using losing a
lot over time
um the idea is yeah you might lose like
a year or two and then when the market
crashes you make way more than you lost
that's how it's supposed to work
uh relaunched it Mark relaunched it in
2007 with universa and pretty good
timing because 2008 uh
saw the global financial crisis and an
interesting story I tell in the book is
how when they launched universa which
people look at now as being this very
successful hedge fund managing billions
of dollars
no one wanted to invest it was such a
weird unique strategy that people just
didn't get it they traveled the country
talking to portfolio managers Pension
funds family offices
and you know everybody looked at this
and said you know wait a second I'm
going to be losing money month after
month on this thing like that's terrible
you know uh traditional Wall Street
strategy is like very smooth consistent
returns
problem is strategies like that often
have what Nasim calls hidden risk and
they can suffer a lot during these
crises so
they have a very lumpy return you know
year after year they're losing several
percent
and then all of a sudden they make a
thousand percent or two thousand percent
and that's it's designed to be like you
know time to crashes protects portfolios
it also gives investors a big chunk of
cash when everything else is down so
they can take that and plow it back into
the market
so you start the book uh talking about
Ackman uh Bill Ackman obviously during
the pandemic um he had put on basically
an insurance protection uh using a
somewhat similar strategy uh a couple
billion dollars there uh that was able
to offset losses in kind of a long
portfolio uh talk a little bit about
this idea that like in this
hyper-connected world people are uh
predicting that there's going to be more
and more volatility and ultimately what
this is doing is it's profiting off of
that volatility and so uh yes Nasim and
Mark seem to have kind of pioneered this
as a standalone fund with a specific
strategy but is it really that different
than maybe some other hedge fund
managers may be doing when they're
hedging or when they're trying to uh
specifically protect the portfolio that
is long
uh it depends on how the strategy is
implemented
so you know what Ackman did in early
2020 was a uh a strategic trade based on
his assessment of what was going on in
the world with the pandemic with markets
and he saw early on that the risk uh
that he understood covid posed to the
world wasn't being priced into assets
yet in say you know February early March
so he was able to load up on these
positions uh pretty cheaply he I think
he only put in like 26 million dollars
and that turned into 2.5 or 2.6 billion
when when the market crashed
so that's a strategic uh trade made on
timing like just similar to what a lot
of the uh you know the big short guys
did for the housing market in the
mid-2000s
that is not what universa does their
strategy is basically
you always have that big short on no
matter what's going on you don't make
any predictions you don't try to time
things it's just there because according
to you know it seems Black Swan uh view
of the world is that nobody can predict
these things they come out of the blue
uh they happen so fast that it's
extremely difficult to to trade on them
like you know Ackman did it uh he I I
see what you know he did in early 2020
was a
Trader you know at the top of this game
I mean he was really moving he he and
one of the crazy things he did was he
you know he got those billions and he
put a lot of it back in the stock market
in March of 2020 which is you know who
who does that but that trade earned him
another billion
um this is something that uh you know
it's just very hard to do on a
consistent basis year after year so the
universe strategy is you don't time
things you just put it on it's a you
know what they recommend is you put
about three percent of your portfolio
into that tail hedge and the rest that
frees up your uh the rest of your cash
to put into stocks now this obviously
become a very very popular strategy if
you just look at the AUM right I think
the latest numbers that you include at
the end of the book is a universe that
has about 20 billion dollars of assets
under management they have 21 employees
right so you have a billion dollars of
AUM for every one employee
um and uh you mentioned that when they
launched they all had 300 million
dollars or so of assets and so as they
have got more and more adoption they've
now become one of the top 25 largest
hedge funds in the world uh when you see
that is that just people uh kind of
buying into the idea of the uh kind of
tail hedge is that them doing a better
job of marketing like what's driving so
much AUM going into that strategy now
and is it something where you know they
went from 300 million to 20 billion on
their way to 100 billion or how do you
see kind of that future life of how big
the fund could actually get
yeah their AUM has moved up and down uh
a lot over the years so it it jumped up
pretty quickly after the global
financial crisis and then it's you know
one of the challenges they've
encountered is keeping investors in the
strategy because after a few years A lot
of them look at it and say Hey you know
I'm losing this money or all these you
know past few years uh I don't think the
Market's gonna crash
everything looks fine and they pull out
so uh I I tell uh some humorous and sad
story really about Calpers uh and how
they were uh making a big investment in
universa and starting around 2016 2017
.
um they were putting billions into
universa and by late 2019
they had about I think a position of
about 5 billion
and then a new manager took over looked
at the tail hedge and said you know this
is a waste of money uh
um we're just losing cash it's never
going to get big enough to matter for us
because we're hundreds of billions uh
big
so in early 2020
a couple months before uh kovid
um really had they eliminated their
entire position uh at University so
that's one of the hard things about this
strategy is is keeping people in it so
Calpers gave up a lot by pulling out
um why why is it so big I think that you
know
the strategy definitely is catching on
uh and more and more funds are getting
into it I've been getting feedback from
fund managers uh tail hedge fund
managers who've read the book and say
like oh it's great you're writing about
this because it's really important
um and it's effective I think people are
starting to figure out it's effective
and just I I write about and as Mark and
Nasim have have talked about their
strategy doesn't fit within the standard
uh portfolio Theory uh propagated on
Wall Street and in finance schools that
try to uh that favor strategies with low
volatility
um that are smooth risk adjusted returns
um you uh you manage your risk and way
to maximize your returns they do pretty
much the opposite of what modern
portfolio Theory recommends they have
extremely volatile returns losses year
after year and then big jumps and that
just doesn't fit within the models I
think that people you know Wall Street
is starting to figure out like okay
doesn't fit the model but it works right
so uh yeah there's a there's a lot more
funds out there University got 20
billion we'll see if it grows maybe you
know people really freaked out after
2020 the pandemic and I think it woke up
a lot of people to the fact that you
know there is increasing risk out there
and you know as globalization expands as
connectivity expands that's you know one
of the driving forces of covid was you
know air airplanes uh people getting on
planes you know from the blonde fashion
show and you know flying back to America
or other parts of Europe carrying the
virus with them
um that a lot of epidemiologists say
this this is a new world we're living in
where these viruses are going to spread
more rapidly and uh you know create the
kind of chaos that we saw that year so I
think that that's
um that's one of the big things that's
driving the the money flows into these
tail headphones what's fascinating to me
about Bolton the seam and Mark is that
that they both kind of figured out this
strategy separately in their past life
before they started the hedge fund right
and you tell both stories uh obviously
um with Naseem kind of doing it in the
finance world and trying to understand
it
um but but also you talk about this
principle of like maybe most of Finance
is based on the idea that uh everything
is normal and then the outlier is the
volatile situation but maybe actually we
should flip that on its head in the
volatile situations are the normal times
and it's the periods of kind of no
volatility that is the outlier and the
reason being you know if you take away
the top 10 trading days a year or
something it's like pretty much flat uh
and you know year in year out and so it
really is all about the big moves either
up or down
um yeah and so is it something where uh
We've almost educated an entire
generation of people in finance in a
perspective that fundamentally Naseem
and Mark just reject because of the work
that they had done uh and kind of the
experience they had going into this
yes I you know I think it's one of the
key insights that they both had is
that it's it's not focusing on the
day-to-day returns those are going to
come you know if you're in the market uh
you don't really need to work that hard
to get those Returns what you really
need to work hard on is the big crashes
and uh Mark likes to talk about
um the scenario that I think is pretty
Illuminating where if you say if you
have a hundred dollars in a in a trade
and it goes down 50 percent in order to
get back to where you were you need to
make a hundred percent return
which is a pretty daunting Mass right so
what you need to do is to protect
yourself against that 50 Decline and if
you can do that you're going to live to
trade another day
and the you know the incremental returns
will just come if you are in the market
you know uh you don't need to have a
real fancy trading strategy
um and yeah I I you know tell the story
about Mark when he was an early you know
Cub Trader at the Chicago Board of Trade
in the 80s and he learned this lesson
with a this veteran commodity Trader uh
Everett clip who taught him something
that's very contrary to uh what what
most investors are told is that you need
to love to lose and uh and this Trader
just beat it into him uh over and over
again telling him you know this is
against human nature of course but you
need to get this into your strategy and
what that meant as a you know Trader on
the floor of the cbot is if your
position starts going down get out of it
just get out of it right away
learn you know live to trade the next
day and you'll survive and you know he
that that is kind of it's very similar
to what Nasim was doing at the same time
by buying these derivative contracts
that usually lose money they're big bets
on Extreme moves
usually doesn't happen so you lose money
on that trade but when it does when you
do get an extremely volatile event you
make you know way more than you lost uh
huge returns you know as like I also
tell the story of naseem's trading on
Black Monday when positions he bought
for you know a couple pennies were
trading for you know four or five bucks
and that's a the magnitude of that
return does not fit within any parameter
of a you know a model it was so far
outside the models that it was something
like a trade that like that could only
happen in you know once every five
universes according to the uh the math
so he learned early on both of them
learned lessons kind of you know from
different perspectives but when they met
in late 99 at New York University
um they uh they had this mind meld where
they get just kind of you know
saw that they were doing the exact same
thing and it just it worked they really
clicked so
they're two very different people as
well right you at one point talk about
how like Mark went a couple of times I
think to kind of the intellectual
debates uh that Naseem would hold he'd
kind of like hold Court in these like
cafes or libraries or whatever and Mark
basically was like I'd rather like jump
off the building right like this is
horrible this is not for me uh I think
you described him as like more serious
uh whereas Naseem was very much like
kind of an academic uh in nature
um is it a thing where Opposites Attract
because you also talk about this idea
like they just enjoyed walking around
New York City or other places and kind
of talking and and you know arguing and
debating and all this type of stuff or
is there something else driving the
relationship as to why they had so much
respect for each other and why they had
been able to work together and and
really kind of pioneer the strategy
yeah they definitely had similar rural
views like they were both into
libertarianism
um they read some of the same
philosophers like popper
uh so there definitely was a chemistry
there that worked
and at the same time like you say
they're totally different uh people the
same is you know he calls himself a
fanuer you know which basically means
like strolling around town aimlessly and
jump you know popping into bookstores
and museums and I always envisioned you
know him wearing these loafers and a
silk scarf uh
you would never as I said you would
never hear Mark spitznagel call himself
a fenor uh he is the opposite of that
yeah
he's the anti-fanuer he's anti-flower
definitely uh he also likes you know
Daredevil uh Hobbies like soaring on
these engineless uh planes
um skateboarding you'd never seen Naseem
taleb on a skateboard I mean I would I
would love to see that uh image but
um so yeah they've got they've got very
you know different uh interests in life
the theme is uh as he will tell you and
I has told me dozens of times uh he does
not see himself as a Wall Street guy as
a traitor as a finance guy uh he wants
to be known as a as a thinker as a
philosopher as a scientist
um which I think he's achieved with his
his books and his research people still
associate him a bit with Wall Street
especially Wall Street people
associating with that but I think more
you know pop like his more popular
images is a you know somebody who writes
these fascinating books of philosophy
and uh whereas Mark is very happy to
call himself a traitor and that's all he
wants to be known as he he has written
some some fascinating books
um but they're they're very trade
oriented books
um so
you know it I think it's why the team
couldn't stick with it he just didn't
have the Love of the Game that Mark does
and Mark uh as I say in the book when
they shut down their first hedge fund
empirica he was Furious he was like this
is a great strategy why are you doing
this don't you realize what we can do
with this
um and the scene was just like I've had
it you know I can't do it anymore I
think he was concerned about the impact
on his health that he was having he
really stressed out uh whereas Mark was
he he believed in the strategy he
understood that you had to go through
these periods of of losing but it was
going to pay off if you know he he
thought so he relaunched it you know
shut down empiric in 2004 started up
University in 2007 and you know it's uh
it's done it's had a very successful run
so he was right so when you think about
um
Naseem and kind of wanting to be more of
the Thinker the philosopher the
scientist you know kind of the
non-trader is it almost um there's a guy
Rob Henderson you could talk about like
luxury beliefs right and the ability to
uh want to be that because you already
made the money right it is like uh uh if
you were just starting out maybe
actually you would be much more focused
on Wall Street because it was about the
pursuit of uh Financial Freedom and then
once you get it now all of a sudden it's
like hey I don't care about that anymore
now I want to be more in this other uh
realm do you get the sense in your
conversations within the scene like
that's part of this is that they
actually had so much success early on
and then that provided the opportunity
to not worry about Wall Street Finance
trading and kind of personal finances
yeah absolutely I mean he's has said
that the money that he made on Black
Monday was more than he's ever made in
anything else nobody really knows how
much he made
um
so he you know he says that gave him
what he calls you money
and he could just go do what he wants I
think he he you know he's always been a
reader uh you know I talked about when
he was a kid growing up in in Lebanon
you know he was reading all these books
he there was a war going on in in Beirut
and he was confined to the seller and he
was just reading and reading and reading
um
so it's it's not like he made money and
said Okay I want to you know become an
intellectual now I think he always was
uh he just
um
gravitated to Wall Street and you know
it was the 80s it was a you know popular
thing to do
um and he he was good at it he was also
pretty good at math
um
so you know I think that the thing is I
was recently talking to him about this
because as you know it seems a very
divisive figure
um on Wall Street he can be very
abrasive and a lot of people just hate
his guts
uh you know for one reason or another uh
either he's attacked them or you know on
Twitter you know or they just think he's
an
um I think part of it is
uh especially among the top tier hedge
fund managers is jealousy
you know I I know a lot of hedge fund
managers uh I covered the industry for
years and they all almost to a one see
themselves as soaring intellectuals
um with uh you know they've they've read
a lot uh
they want to write a book
many of them many some have written
books
haven't done that well and uh he he's
kind of done what they all
you know secretly want to do is become
you know this popular thinker not known
for the money that they've made but is
being you know intellectual genius
um and I just think that there's there's
a lot of jealousy going on there with
him so you don't know this but uh during
his uh transition from Bitcoin supporter
to bitcoin critic he uh he came at me
viciously and uh I said to myself I was
like yeah I I uh I said look man I got
no problem with them I still uh think of
him in uh incredibly high regard but uh
I do think that you know part of the
public like attacking of other people
definitely you know puts bad taste in
some people's mouth
um but I always do Wonder yeah is that a
requirement right for if you're so
contrarian if you have such a high
disagreeableness like we know that you
have to be contrarian and right uh in
order to kind of make out size returns
does that just kind of come with the
territory and if you think of you know
Sports as an example uh Michael Jordan
or Kobe Bryant or you know name your you
know favorite sports person they got
some you know skeletons in the closet of
Personality that uh people just kind of
chalk up and like well it's the best you
know basketball player of all time like
what'd you expect he was just gonna be
like this nice guy like no he's a killer
right and it seems like Talib maybe has
uh a little bit of that as well uh and
maybe that leads to some of the the
abrasiveness
totally and he's always been like that
um just looking back at comments that he
was making in the 90s uh about financial
models and how stupid many of them are
um and I think it it took somebody like
him to uh to just say so forcefully that
wall Street's got a problem
it's using all these models that hide
risk and cut out the tails
you know like value at risk he's been
you know complaining about value at risk
for decades since the 90s
um I found some old writing from him
that you know it was about how flawed
that was as a risk model
and yet every Bank every hedge fund uses
it uh
and you know it it works 95 of the time
but what you know why would you use a
model that cuts out the most volatile
days five percent of the time over the
year and say oh you know okay we're fine
most of the time these outliers are
going to come along and you know uh
we'll deal with them when you know so
everybody's looking at the you know the
middle of the bell curve and the seam is
saying no that is that is not what you
need to think about you need to think
about those Tails because those are
going to kill you if if you don't
protect against those and that's really
um I think more than anything The
Innovation that he brought
it many people criticize them and you
can look at you know
it one of the chief criticisms he's had
to endure is people saying no we all
knew about tails and you can find
going back decades and you know research
showing that there's these volatile
events there's these fat tails
um and you know people were aware of
them but they weren't incorporating them
into their trading models because it
screwed everything up you know I saw
some email exchanges that he he shared
with me with a very senior Financial
theorist a Nobel Prize winner actually
and this Nobel Prize winner was telling
Naseem yeah we know about the fat tails
but the problem is when we put them into
our models it makes things a lot harder
and it's difficult to trade on them and
and it seems like well you know okay
you're you're ignoring reality and
that's going to be a problem for you and
it's kind of funny like after the global
financial crisis value at risk was just
completely discredited
um I know we at the Wall Street Journal
we wrote about it and how this is one of
the problems that the banks had is that
they you know they didn't see the risk
in the in the housing market because
they were just looking at these average
returns over years and didn't you know
it wasn't even in the models and even a
lot of the derivatives that were used
were using these bell curve models with
no fat tails
and yet if you if you look at any uh
Financial disclosure from a major bank
right now
they're using value at risk they're same
thing and that's how they're managing
their risk now I think that a lot more
are aware of being uh you know concerned
about the Tails and probably are
implementing uh hedge strategies
so hopefully you know that that will
protect them the next time there's a
crash but you know in early 2020 If the
Fed hadn't come in with liquidity
injections like these massive liquidity
injections and buying bonds and even
junk bonds
um the you know we would have seen the
same cascading failures again as we we
saw in 2008 so it's the fed that's
managing the tail risk right now it's
fascinating to think that
um you know Mark spitznagel now with
universa which Nasim I think is still an
advisor to but but universa has become
probably based on everything I've seen
the best performing hedge fund over the
last you know 10 or 15 years
um I think in the book you uh when you
kind of draw the line on the returns
they've averaged over a hundred percent
annual returns for more than a decade
right and and we've heard of you know
those are audited uh returns yeah so
like you know we've heard of obviously
Renaissance and kind of 60 plus percent
um and you know these kind of almost
video game numbers but Universal
specifically uh having 100 annual
returns over a decade is pretty
impressive
um but it feels like uh where Nasim is
very public and he's constantly going on
television he's constantly you know kind
of out there as that thinker as that
philosopher uh Mark is much more
reserved he kind of is hanging out on
his farm and uh yeah he wrote the books
but I don't see him
you know kind of volunteering to go and
do interviews very often and things like
that and so is that just his personality
or how did you read into that
yeah I think he's definitely not nearly
as uh interested in appearing in public
as museum is uh I think it also
you know kind of enhances the Mystique
of it you don't see Jim Simons of
Renaissance uh coming on TV
um and in terms of returns I'd you know
The Medallion fund at Renaissance is
probably unmatched and be for one thing
it's
um it's
big it's really big I don't know how
much how big it is now but it's You know
what last time I was uh looking looking
at that phone I think was 50 billion
and to get the 80 Returns on something
like that year after year is is
mind-blowing
um I was actually the first reporter to
get inside the Renaissance office
uh more than a decade ago when when
Simons was stepping down
um and I I knew people so I've written a
lot about them but universities
you can't say that that just moved on
what was that like when you go in the
Renaissance office
yeah it was it was cool because they
brought us into their server room
which had all you know these computer uh
big computers
um
and I thought that was fascinating
because I was you know looking at these
computers and thinking like what is
going on inside those things
um everybody wants to know they've
always been
you know uh
a uh source of speculation and and
mystery
on Wall Street because they they seem to
have cracked the code uh and they've got
all these phds and you know so we walked
around the office uh it was funny it was
like they're off parts of the building
that had a bunch of Chinese programmers
and then you go down a floor and they're
like here's where the Russians are
um so yeah it was it was very
interesting
when you think of uh spitznegle today
you mentioned multiple times about the
book that he's like on Zoom with his
Traders from his farm uh
what what is that about like is this
just uh because he's only got 21
employees and the strategy is kind of so
simple and just it's about discipline
it's not necessarily about day-to-day
decision making uh he's able to uh spend
time doing other things or is there
something else that we should take away
from that
I think
I think um it can be
and this is just me speculating because
I don't really know what they do day to
day aside from
you know they're buying these uh far out
of the money put options
um but I think there is a bit of a
machine like quality to the strategy
and he doesn't need to be in the room uh
every day when things are happening he
can see what you know what they're doing
what the what the portfolio is doing
um and uh so it's easy enough for him to
you know get on Zoom I think probably he
has done a lot more of that uh since the
pandemic like everybody
um but if something crazy happens he can
jump on a plane and be in uh Miami in in
you know four or five hours
yeah and then when you look out at
um kind of the strategy itself uh even
you seem to be a little bit like okay I
get the general strategy but how do they
actually do it is probably one of the
number one questions you get uh yeah
what level of confidence could you say
that you could go and explain to someone
like the intricacies and the nuances is
it something where they really are kind
of close to their chest even though the
the describe kind of the high level but
they won't explain the details or is it
that the details are so complex that
it's just really hard for people to wrap
their heads around
again I can only speculate
um but you know I think that uh a big
part of their strategy which you can't
replicate you know on your you know
interactive brokers trading account is
having relationships on well-established
relationships on Wall Street that can
allow you to put on these big positions
in uh these derivatives these options
that nobody else wants you know I think
they also have the stomach and the the
uh market knowledge to to know that
these positions
you know which look like you know
practically idiotic trades uh
are gonna pay off and you you just got
to keep doing it because their their
trade is a bet on a 20 decline in the S
P 500 in a month
which is pretty nuts like you know I
think it's it's only happened a couple
times
um when they launched University the
only time that had happened was in 1987
when the the Dow went down
22.7 percent in a single day
um so that was one of the reasons they
had a lot of trouble getting investors
was you know they look at it and say
well this never happens so you know why
would I put money into that
um but I think one of the serious
strategy is it doesn't you don't
actually need a 20 decline for those
those options to Surge in value
you just need there to be a lot of fear
uh in the market that that could happen
and that creates a you know sort of
feeding frenzy on those positions
everybody suddenly wants them because it
helps balance out their risk in their
portfolios and universities there to
provide that when everybody wants it
they're the ones who have those
positions
um they talk about like you know they're
the only ones with
umbrella an umbrella selling umbrellas
when the storm breaks out
um and so you can sell your umbrellas at
a high premium
so it's you know I think it's just the
market knowledge it's the the contacts
that they have
um but I the difficulty of the strategy
is maintaining it in the most cost
effective manner that you can because if
if you're trying to do this from your
interactive brokers account you're
probably going to lose a lot of money uh
month after month year after year and at
some point most people I think are going
to cut and run and say forget that you
know but I'm I'm losing money and you
know and they don't have they either
don't have the the cash to keep it up or
the stomach to keep it up
talk to me about the risk of ruin that
seems to be one of the things that um
really kind of drives you know part of
their marketing but also I think across
Wall Street you know people realize hey
you can compound capital for a really
really long time and it doesn't take
that uh much to just all of a sudden
lose it all
um and obviously these Market crashes
that's a huge thing
um and something you talk about
throughout the book why is that so
important you think as part of their
marketing
uh well it's I think it's a real risk
especially when you're uh using Leverage
so you know if you're if you're in
trades that are 30 to 1
20 to one you don't need the market to
go down that much to completely wipe you
out
um so that's the risk of Ruin it's also
known as gambler's ruin
you know it's like Russian Roulette if
you you know you can
spin the barrel a couple times and you
might live but if you keep doing it
you're gonna blow your head off and
that's kind of what uh the ruin risk is
um is
you may survive uh you know like if you
go in a casino and you put all your
money down on red
you might make it a couple times but
eventually if you keep doubling down
you're going to lose all your money
and that's uh that's the risk they say
that they avoid uh with the strategies
that they cannot blow up and
you know that's the trade that
originally was empirica
uh Naseem wanted to devise a strategy
that can't blow up it can bleed
um and you can lose money
over an extended period of time but
there's no leverage in it it's just a
you know you're buying these options
they expire you've you know lost the
money on that investment
but there's no way that you can in a big
downturn
um with that strategy that you can lose
everything you actually make a lot it's
the you know people know naseem's book
anti-fragile
um but I think that he he hasn't told me
this but I think that he must have
gotten a concept with this strategy
because it's the ultimate anti-fragile
strategy these put options
uh you know you can lose the money on
them but when there's a you know big
episode of volatility they become
anti-fragile they become extremely
valuable
it's fascinating to think about the one
thing everyone worries about in blowing
up they figured out a way to hang their
hat and say that's the one thing that we
can ensure won't happen right and it's
almost this uh again this contrarian
nature uh to it
um talk about
um
the forty four hundred percent return So
at the beginning of uh covid I think it
was in March of uh of kovid
um they reported uh at Universal 4 400
return there was a lot of people who
were kind of you know breath taken away
and they're like oh my God that's an
incredible return then there's a lot of
critics who are like that's you
know they lost money before and all the
the critiques that came out how do you
look at that uh kind of just massive
number that they posted in what was one
of the most recent you know really big
Market downturns
it's probably where most people don't
understand how Universe operates and how
they report their returns
so you know
a lot of funds typically
report uh like if they're a hundred
billion dollar fund and
they went up to 2 billion they're going
to say we had 100 return
so universe is managing uh what they are
actually doing is they're protecting
assets and when they tell they disclose
their AUM what they're actually
disclosing is the amount of assets that
they have uh a protection portfolio on
so if they have you know they're
protecting 5 billion in assets it's not
like they have 5 billion in the market
they actually have a very a small
percentage of that 5 billion actually in
the Market at any given time of just a
few percentage points of that
and that position that sort of overlay
uh on the portfolio that they're
protecting
that what that does is that's what the
four thousand plus percent return is on
so it's the return on the options that
they had bought
during that period of extreme volatility
in early 2020 that's where you get the 4
000 plus percent return
and so what does that look like in terms
of if they had a hundred dollars in the
fund if there's a few percentage points
let's say they had one to five dollars
actually deployed at the time in those
options for forty four hundred percent
return that gets them still hundreds of
percent on the total Capital but it's
not the forty four hundred percent on on
the entire fund size
right which would be crazy right you
know four thousand percent on five
billion
um I mean anybody who knows the strategy
anything about it they they'd know that
that's not what they were saying but
they you know people still like to
criticize them because either they're
you know competitors or
jealous or they just like to throw mud
at
Naseem and Mark
um but you know I talked to uh tail
hedge managers and
there what I think irritates some of
their competitors is that they don't
report in the same way
that universa does
um and they're like well yeah I could
have said I made two thousand percent or
three thousand percent and and early
2020 but that's not how we report our
returns
and I'm like okay you know that's fine
Universe you know is the original tail
hedge fund they created the strategy and
I I feel like is you know that gives
them the right to do report returns
however they want yeah what's been the
most surprising part I mean you've known
these guys for a while
um as you wrote the book what what was
the part that kind of stuck out to you
or maybe the biggest Insight that that
you weren't expecting
I think that you know how how you can
take this world view that they've
learned at as a Trader as an asset
manager and managing risk and how that
can be applied to other parts of the
world
um like uh you know
climate risk is is something that I
write about in the book and and
something the seam has has written about
uh and you know with risks like that you
have there's these potential extreme
events that could happen you don't
really know statistically How likely it
is
um but you know the the uncertainty
of the potential outcome of these risks
is so high that you need to be very
careful about managing that risk and I
think that you know with black swans in
the market
um you don't know it's going to happen
uh you don't know that there's going to
be a crash but
the uncertainty about
the potential of it means that you need
to be pretty careful about it you know
like Nasim likes to say if you don't
have trust in the pilot don't get on the
plane it's the uncertainty
of the possibility of these extreme
events that people need to take into
consideration
but it's also uncertainty that causes
people to say well you know we don't
really know how bad this is why should
we take precautions against it because
we don't really understand it that well
and you know you saw that with covid in
2020 was there were a lot of people
especially early on saying well we need
to study this thing more because we
don't understand the properties and how
contagious it is or how deadly it is so
let's just wait and see and uh figure it
out and then we can decide what to do
and it's that wait and see uh mentality
that's the problem is we wait too long
and game over you know and uh I think
that's part you know partly what uh
caused the Us and other countries to
have such you know High fatality rates
in 2020 2021
um and you know it's uh I I think that
the original idea of the book actually
came in early 2020 when I saw what
universa did
and around the same time Naseem and some
co-authors had written a paper in
January of 2020 warning about the uh
potential extreme risks that covid posed
and saying we really need to be careful
with this thing it poses the risk of
Ruin uh let's take precautions
um they were actually in contact with
officials at the White House and they
they communicated that paper to the
White House
um and it made me think like what is it
about nasim's ability to see the extreme
risk posed by covid that kind of maps
over onto what universa did because it's
you know the same time you have you know
two people who have been engaged in the
same Market activities
coming out looking pretty smart when
everybody else is in total chaos and
losing money uh not understanding covid
um that's the thing that I thought you
know what is it about their the way that
they see the world that enabled them to
get through this period of crazy risk
and come out looking pretty smart
and then when you look at
um spit sneagle what do you think
separates him from kind of everyone else
right is it
something about the discipline and you
know even uh Naseem kind of said hey I
don't want to do this anymore right I
don't want to deal with uh uh almost the
mundane kind of nature of it uh maybe he
didn't want to be the front man whatever
but like spitznickel has stayed with
this the entire time what is it that
separates yeah
um yeah well I you know I write about
how when he was growing up he was a very
intense kid
and apparently like he told me he'd walk
around his house uh muttering to himself
saying discipline discipline discipline
and at the time that was about his uh
practicing uh on the French horn and he
actually became like a you know one of
the best French horn players in America
and was accepted to Juilliard and was
going to become a professional French
horn player
um and then apparently uh
his brother told me the story that he he
found out how much like the uh first see
French horn player and you know New York
Symphony made per year and it was like
less than a high school
teacher made
um and he said forget that uh and it you
know around the same time he'd started
uh going to the Chicago Board of Trade
and just became fascinated with it he
just fell in love with it you know I
tell the story of how his father one day
brought him to the seabot and
he he wasn't at all what he expected and
he you know the energy of it he just
fell in love with it and I think it just
something in him clicked
that you know was like this is this is
for me like I wanted I want to do this
and he just dove into it and it's just
all you know I think he's it's just a
natural fit he's a he's a natural-born
Trader and uh the discipline that he
learned you know under a clip about
learning to lose I think that mentality
has separated him from most other uh
traders who who do not like Clues
um it's also you know I mean if you
think about the incentive structures on
Wall Street
you you most uh people Traders or money
managers whatever they have their eye on
their annual bonus
um which that's all that matters for
them is how big that bonus is going to
be
year after year
if you're losing money
year after year you don't get a bonus
there's no bonus so the incentive
structures on Wall Street are just
designed uh to
pretty much force traders to adopt a
strategy that's going to give them uh
you know steady returns
but they're taking this risk and I think
that you know the bet is well if I can
if I can hang on for five years you know
and before I blow up I'm gonna do I'm
gonna have you know a lot of money
um maybe they can make it longer than
that but uh
um that's not the way Universe operates
they you know they make their money very
incrementally or very very uh rarely
and you know I asked uh I asked them you
know how do you get your traders to
stick with this because
they don't have that you know uh
incentive of the big bonus at the end of
the year
and they said the way they get them to
think about it is like having an option
uh for in a company and you know when it
goes public you're gonna make a lot
you're gonna you know it might be
um you know a few years where you're
you're not gonna get much of return but
when those options pay off
you're gonna get a lot
I want to read you a quote this is uh a
banker talking about a gentleman named
uh Suleiman Olean he's one of the
richest guys in Saudi Arabia built a
massive uh conglomerate a bunch of
different businesses and his Banker said
the following you could see clearly that
he wanted to be successful you didn't
see him in bars or nightclubs he was a
serious person he was always looking for
new business and he wanted to seize
every bit of opportunity that came his
way he was almost compulsively ambitious
the reason why I thought of that
specific phrase is he was a serious
person you could clearly see he wanted
to be successful like all these points
of this Banker talking about Suleiman is
very similar to what you're saying about
uh Mark spitznagel but then it talks
about he was almost compulsively
ambitious and one of the interesting
things about this strategy is to some
degree you have to temper ambition of
doing things outside of the strategy of
losing discipline of trying to get too
smart or too greedy and so it's
fascinating to me right and I think you
can kind of reading the book of like you
have to be ambitious enough to want to
do this and kind of stick with it but
you also have to be self-aware enough to
know that if you get greedy if you
become undisciplined you basically ruin
the strategy and all of the value you
know dissipates very quickly right
yeah yeah it's it's a model it's a it's
a strategy and you know nasima said he's
never seen mark
stray from the model
once uh the the the protocol as they
call the Black Swan protocol
um so he it's it is definitely
discipline
um and it's I think it's just hard to do
and one important thing about the
universal strategy uh you know as I
point out in the book is
this is not designed to be a
strategy for your whole portfolio no one
would put all their money into a
universal fund you you actually based on
the historic returns you actually would
have done pretty well
um you know very lumpy uh gains uh it's
meant to be a overlay of a broader
portfolio of stocks and maybe some bonds
so you know what Mark says is we
recommend our clients that you put three
percent uh into our fund and the rest
you can put into stocks and the idea is
that you know traditional portfolios
um you know that many Pension funds
follow is the 60 40 strategy UH 60 in
the stock market 40 in bonds or other
less risky assets like you know maybe
some gold and uh currencies commodities
um
the problem with that strategy according
to Mark is that you're giving up a lot
of upside in the market and that's
really where your Returns come from and
the market has historically
uh done pretty well
uh the problem is that the market can be
really volatile sometimes and go down a
lot so if you
protect yourself during those volatile
times and you have a trade that will
give you this big infusion of cash uh
when everything is down and or you know
more attractive
uh that you're going to do pretty well
over time and and that's basically in a
nutshell what what their strategy is
it's fascinating when you see
um how long they've been doing this
um and you mentioned that there's a lot
of people on Wall Street that have
started to kind of wake up to this do
you anticipate that there will be many
many more copycats uh including could we
see a BlackRock uh or other types of you
know Fidelity like very very large asset
managers start to introduce these
strategies as well
um they you know some are and there's
some ETFs that are coming out
uh
I somehow suspect that if the market
continues to be pretty calm and and you
know trade up and down but you know not
the volatility that we saw in 2020 I
kind of bet that you know the popularity
of the trade is going to fade
um and yeah as we've seen before I mean
after 2008 a bunch of copycats jumped in
and uh launched their tail hedge funds
and
hung around for a few years but it's
just the nature of this strategy that
it's very tough to maintain uh over a
long period of time so we'll see I mean
you know universe is obviously attracted
a lot of money and and that's going to
cause people to say hmm I I like uh I
like those uh
um management fees so yeah there might
be some more but we'll see I'm a bit
skeptical
Scott chaos Kings is the name of the
book how Wall Street Traders make
billions in the new age of Crisis uh it
is not only fascinating from education
standpoint I think that uh one of your
skills is you also write in a very
entertaining fashion so people can kind
of read it you just keep wanting to read
more and more I really enjoyed this book
so anyone who wants to go pick it up
chaos Kings Scott Patterson I highly
suggest you do that I'm assuming you can
buy this Amazon or any of the uh various
books uh also audiobook ebook or
physical book but Scott if somebody
wants to find you on the internet or
kind of follow up with you anything you
talked about today where can we send
them
uh yeah I'm on Twitter uh at Patterson
Scott I've got a website uh Scott
pattersonbooks.com
and uh yeah if you find the book on
Amazon or uh Barnes Noble
forever awesome well listen I really
appreciate you taking the time to do
this uh as I mentioned the book is
fantastic so I appreciate you
entertaining me for a couple hours as I
uh as I read it and uh we'll definitely
have to bring you back when you write
the next one
would love to